das riesige erdbeben in kalifornien ist
überfällig wird big one so werden solche
mega beben genannt 1906 kam es zum
letzten mal zu einem mega beben in der
region es war die schlimmste
naturkatastrophe der usa mit einer
erdbebenstärke von 8,46 meter verschoben
sich damals die pazifische und die
nordamerikanische platte genauso viel
müssten die beiden platten sich jetzt
wieder gegeneinander verkantet haben in
der letzten woche gab es vier erdbeben
entlang des feuerrings der pazifischen
platte und jetzt wird vermutet dass ein
beben in kalifornien bevorstehen könnte
alles über das drohende erdbeben das
mega-beben in kalifornien jetzt
praktisch zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
am 18 april 1906 um 5 uhr 12 bebte die
erde rund um san francisco
es erreichte eine stärke von 8,4 und
zerstörte san francisco weitestgehend
vor allem die feuer
nach dem erdbeben waren absolut
zerstörerisch ein großteil der
bevölkerung wurde obdachlos und 3000
menschen starben ein weiteres solches
erdbeben ist unvermeidlich darüber sind
sich alle im klaren aber wann wird es
stattfinden wenn man sich die
verschiebung der erdplatten von damals
ansieht müsste es schon bald so weit
sein 6 zentimeter pro jahr verschieben
sich die pazifische und die
nordamerikanische platte gegeneinander
bezogen auf das erdbeben von 1906 sind
es also jetzt schon 60 zentimeter mehr
als damals aber ob ein erdbeben
stattfindet und wo das hängt von so
vielen faktoren ab das sind
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
einfach nichts dazu sagen können oder
wollen doch jetzt schrillen die
alarmglocken in der letzten woche gab es
vier erdbeben rund um die pazifische
platte
es bebte auf neuseeland indonesien japan
und dem ozeanischen vanuatu und dabei
hatten die beben in mexiko damit
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts zu tun
denn dort bebte die erde entlang der
karibischen und der cocos platte das
muster der beben entlang der pazifischen
platte war dabei sehr ungewöhnlich wie
seismologen gary gibson von der
universität melbourne festgestellt hat
in der daily mail aus trader sagt er
diese ungewöhnliche muster zeigen sich
öfter und scheinen nicht vollkommen
zufällig wir können uns aber noch keinen
reim darauf machen mit anderen worten
nichts genaues weiß man nicht es scheint
so als ob sich die beben durch
seismische wellen entlang des rings of
fire des feuerrings rund um die
pazifische platte gegenseitig ausgelöst
hätten
der feurigen der wird so genannt da
entlang der kante der pazifischen platte
immer wieder vulkane ausbrechen
durch die bruchkante kann manchmal sehr
leicht an die erdoberfläche gelangen ob
aber diese jetzt festgestellten
seismischen aktivitäten ein erdbeben in
kalifornien auslösen können dass es
vollkommen unsicher nur eins ist sicher
es wird dort in kalifornien ein erdbeben
geben und es wird heftig sein aber ob es
nächste woche nächstes jahr oder in den
nächsten 10
dann passieren wird das kann niemand
sagen wenn es neue erkenntnisse dazu
gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier bei
pixum wenn ihr kein video zum thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann sollten wir hier ein abo auf
saure und vergesslich den genau auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit erdbeben
in deutschland da geht es um die gefahr
von erdbeben hier in deutschland die
gibt es nämlich auch ja und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran